Lebanon really is in a bad way and its
economy ministry is at the heart of
international talks to bring this place
back from the brink
realm now may is the minister here
appointed five months ago as part of a
government of technocrats he speaks not
like a politician but like The Economist
he is a storm crisis that is in my
opinion and seen worldwide we are paying
the price of a bad management of the
economy and for 30 years and we are
paying that today this is what a
collapsed economy looks like families
evicted from homes and struggling even
to afford food this week we filmed with
Elias trying to hold his family together
how critical is the situation right now
look the situation right now is as I
said before extremely critical you know
we are already probably above the 50%
poverty line about 50% poverty line we
need to do a lot to help people to be
able to continue to to live and have a
minimum at hand every two hours
electricity a day in in the capital of
Lebanon I mean that's just terrible
isn't it yes it is terrible and not only
terrible it's absolutely incredible but
this is a situation wherein the minister
said this darkness wasn't because of a
lack of cash but a supply problem
the frustration on the streets is almost
daily and talks with the International
Monetary Fund have been ongoing for
weeks but still there is no bailout
agreed in large part because politicians
inside the country can't agree on the
scale of the losses or the required I
mean it seems to me that the IMF is
saying look we want to give you money we
want to help you but you need to get
your own house in order you can't even
agree on the scale of the losses the
government says it's some two hundred
and forty one trillion lebanese pounds
or something and others in parliament
and the bank say it's it's far less than
that if you can't even agree amongst
yourselves about how much you owe and
how much you need how can you expect
others to help you look I think it has
been very clearly stated by IMF that our
numbers are the government adds right
numbers everything else in my opinion is
just not acceptable but assume is to
assume that the numbers are right that
that the IMF goes for it gives you a
loan how are you going to get your
Parliament to agree to that I think at
the end of the day they will have to
agree to it and everybody will have to
agree to it because number one these are
the right numbers and number two we have
no choice but to go to IMF as I told you
so as we sit here today how likely do
you think it is that a a deal a bailout
with the IMF will be a we're talking 50
percent chance 25 percent in my opinion
100 percent the only question is when
and what's the answer to that but I
don't know the answer to that it's
whenever everybody for example in the
Parliament understands that really we
have no other choice so how are the
politicians have to understand that this
this is and and understand it you know
and absorb it and say yes okay at the
end of the day IMF is a solution it
doesn't mean accepting all the
conditions of IMF but I am a physicist
what about looking east
that was certainly a suggestion by
Hassan Nasrallah the leader of Hezbollah
China Iran is China a genuine prospect
could you ask China for money
if I don't think first that China we
give any dollar without I enough let's
put it this way no investor will put $1
if he is not sure that he will get it
back once IMF program is on and reforms
are gone and so on my answer is is yes
I don't think Iran in the current
geopolitical situation is is a solution
that we could look into are we looking
at essentially a failed state here in
Lebanon well of course it is a failed
failed state in the sense that the
economic crisis is such that the
everything has collapsed basically now
the government is doing in my opinion
whatever is needed to be able to get out
of this crisis it will be painful it
will be long but it will happen I am
very confident that at the end of the
road the light is there at the end of
the tunnel the light is there we will
get out of it but it must be said that
is not an optimism that is reflected on
the streets mark stone Sky News in
Beirut